3JS tends to create what are called canonical objects. This is where you create
an object centered around the origin and then apply a series of transforms to
move it into position. This is fine so far as it goes, but is sometimes awkward
when you want to perform particular kinds of modeling. For example, if I want to
make a model where I want chains of cones to build a tree, I might rather say
where I want each end of the cone to be located. This sort of modelling where I
run a program to generate an object is called procedural model. I want to orient
the cone, given the top and bottom locations. That'll be your task. In the
cullen routine the top and bottom variables are vector three positions given the
ends of the cone. You'll see documentation for the other variables in the code
itself. Your task is to implement the internals of this method. Actually, I
decided to simplify a major piece for you. Mainly because it has a special case
having to do with a cross product. I implemented this function myself. So your
job is to create the proper length cylinder and feed this method its axis
direction and center. When you get the answer right, you'll see this on your
screen. I gave a lot of test cones here, and in fact, a few of these revealed
some bugs in my own code when I was writing it. If you ever design a component
like this, they will be used by others. I highly recommend that you try to
create as many different types of test cases as you can.